oh hello there is this election wearing
you out already want to hear a love
story it's the one about the eager
billionaires behind the 2016 election
here is a look at some of the hottest
sugar daddies ready to tease and please
White House hopefuls
a first is Norman Braman when this stud
finds someone he commits that's why he
only has eyes for a certain Latin Lover
Marco Rubio the former Philadelphia
Eagles owner has been backing his bay's
career for years paying hundreds of
thousands of dollars to the Rubio's
personally now he's so far bankrolled
one-fifth of the pro Rubio super PAC the
young senator says Bremen is like a
father figure and what do politicians do
for their father figures steer taxpayer
funds towards their favorite causes
naturally Marco did good for day it's
two for the price of one with brothers
Faris and Dan Wilkes hmm they've given a
combined 15 million to a cruise pack one
of the largest pac donations ever these
bible thumping billionaires made their
money in fracking and they will frack
you all night long with their uber
conservative views hatred of abortion
denying gays equal rights oh the mere
mention of climate change will get these
two going think their money doesn't buy
love well the Texas state legislators
who received Wilkes money happen to
disagree they also happen to vote for a
pro-fracking bill that the brothers were
thrusting for natural gas political love
potion
think liberals don't have high money
libidos oh they get their donors up big
time like the Manhattan mogul George
Soros he might have a third wife 42
years his junior but when it comes to
politics he's all about this cougar mmm
he's already dished out eight million
big ones to Hillary Clinton's super PAC
Soros chairs a foundation that promotes
human rights around the world but he
won't just put out for nothing it'll eat
email a friend of Clinton said that
soros appreciates his direct line to
this seasoned madam do you like your
billionaires and make the first move
then you'll love media magnate Heim
Sabon he's a friend with benefits to the
Clintons he's enjoyed sleepovers at the
White House and the Clintons have
lavished in his 10 million dollar gift
to their foundation in this race he's so
far slipped a cool five mil into a pro
Hillary PAC sabon wants Hillary to be
down for one thing only Israel hmm keep
talking dirty and Hillary yearns for sue
bonds experience on Israel Palestine
last year she asked him what should be
done about the boycott divestment and
sanctions movement and if she's elected
subhan will make sure to build
settlements all over her presidency so
there you have it the man pulling hearts
and pulling strings in American politics
which one will get lucky after making it
rain this hard
you